unless you're a total Disney fan we bet
you've never heard of some of these
unofficial Disney Princesses stick
around until the end to let us know how
many of these you've heard before now
let's check out which Disney Princesses
are totally forgotten Giselle from
Enchanted let's start with one that
makes Disney fans feel the most
passionate when it comes to the whole
Forgotten Princesses Giselle could
easily be up there with the official
Disney Princesses but for some reason
she was left out the only things that
touched sure this Disney movie comes
with a real-life scenario - but that's
what makes it so special
Giselle is also the only princess that
lives in her stereotypical Disney
princess world as well as real-life
[Music]
breakfast great and we all know that
those are completely different the real
life totally challenges her slightly
naive personality and she ends up
completely changing she becomes a pretty
decent mother figure - Roberts daughter
Morgan - seriously guys Giselle is just
one of those princesses that doesn't
deserve enough credit at all well I'm
sorry I was thinking Enchanted itself is
a pretty adorable movie especially since
it combines the cartoon and the
real-life world we just love it whenever
princesses come to life seriously has
anyone started a petition for Giselle to
be an official Disney Princess already
because if not someone really should
make this happen melody from The Little
Mermaid to return to the sea you know we
have talked about melody - she belongs
to the often overlooks to the Little
Mermaid sequel called return to the sea
but this movie is the ultimate after
happily ever after
[Music]
melody is Ariel and Eric's daughter and
she's pretty much the exact opposite of
her mother she's a total tomboy but the
two do share a few similarities melody
for example also loves to collect items
but she collects things from the sea not
from the land of course she would since
she lives on land anyways come my
darling your disk to me oh wait she's
also a good singer and just like her
mother
and she's a pretty decent dancer being a
half mermaid Melody's life is a bit
complicated and she's often seen as the
outcast by normal people but that
doesn't stop her from having an
amazingly sassy personality and
perfectly relatable lines disaster
seriously melodie deserves your full
attention and you should definitely see
the little mermaid to return to the sea
just because of her she totally deserves
a Disney Princess spot Jane from Tarzan
I Tarzan you Jane Tarzan is one of the
underrated movies that really makes you
totally forget about the potential Jane
had to be a Disney Princess Jane is an
animal researcher she comes from a
middle class but she doesn't really act
like it
[Music]
you'd expect her to be snotty and bratty
at all times but Jane actually quickly
adjusts to the jungle life without any
difficulties sure she's still a bit
arrogant and slightly naive but she
voluntarily puts herself out of her
comfort zone Oh baby baby monkey
terrific chuckles girl suddenly cuckoo
stops crying this of course forces
Tarzan to save her but that's besides
the point she's also one of the few
unofficial princesses with a totally
regular profession come on name one
other princess that was a zoologist
Jane's also a pretty good artist which
comes in handy when she has to sketch
the animals she eventually becomes
completely in love with Tarzan and is
totally determined to leave the English
life behind come on how many princesses
would choose to leave their royal
castles to go live in the wild life
Jane is a one-of-a-kind absolutely so
afraid that you wouldn't come in time
and let's not forget about her unique
speaking voice which is definitely not
as soft and melodic as you'd expect
kiddo
from Atlantis if you want to see a
slightly different Disney movie you
should add Atlantis on your list it's
where you'll meet get up a character
mini Disney fans take as the totally
forgotten Disney Princess
let's be honest we bet Kida is a name
you've never heard of before in the
Disney franchise but you definitely
should because she'll make you rethink
how you see Disney Princesses the
official Atlantis story begins with Kida
being evacuated from Atlantis as a child
she later joins a group of researchers
that help her discover Atlantis's
history and life she also pretty much
becomes an actual Queen which is really
impressive we are not thriving through
our people live but our culture is dying
we won't spoil the actual movie because
it's just one of those you have to see
we're also introduced to the researcher
milo who goes on to be kiddoes
significant other but these two totally
don't kiss at all in the entire movie
which is really rare for a Disney couple
in a true Disney stereotype a kiss could
pretty much solve all your problems and
had to fix your entire life Disney fans
have actively tried to campaign for
kiddo to be the next Disney Princess you
do swim do you not oh I swim pretty girl
pretty good pretty good
rumor has it that Disney thinks kid is
too old she'd be around 8,000 years old
which would make her at the oldest
Disney Princess ever we can see how that
would be a problem but come on she's the
most perfect character to be considered
for a princess princess amber from Sofia
the first Sofia the first might seem
like it's a bit too babyish for most but
if you're a Disney fan you should miss
out on this series let's be real it's a
guilty pleasure for even some of the
adult Disney fans your party is going to
be fabulous no because you what the
series features plenty of Disney
Princesses and many of their original
voice actresses princess amber is one of
those you either totally love or hate
she really has no middle ground she is
known to be pretty spoiled and bratty as
well as totally manipulative as her
character progressed she was given a
slightly more caring side and she showed
she truly loves her family so welcome to
your day-off
do-over party sure she still has some of
her old mean-spirited ways but her
character is actually developing into a
slightly nicer princess plus you know
that all the best Disney Princesses come
with just a bit of an attitude
so her cold demeanor is perfectly fine
an hour
no matter what I do I'm always stuck
with you
however Princess amber is largely
ignored as a princess because let's be
honest people pretty much dismissed her
because of her manipulative attitude at
the beginning seriously guys
she does get better later on Ariel
sisters from The Little Mermaid Ariel is
in the spotlight a lot and she's an
official Disney Princess but you know
who people really forget about her
sisters Ariel has six older sisters a
quater Audrina Arista Edina Adela and
Alana they're not the main part of the
movie at all but they do make a few
brief appearances it's actually the
sisters that are totally able to tell
Ariel is in love not much is known about
their characters which is perhaps why
they're largely forgotten good morning
girls even in the second movie only four
out of the six sisters actually have
dialogue nobody knows how old they are
but it is assumed that Athena is the
oldest as the little mermaid Ariel's
beginning DVD suggests the sisters
definitely appear in every single little
mermaid story but they're never given
enough spotlight and backstory the world
above is a wonderful place maybe it's
time for Disney to build a story around
these forgotten sisters that should
definitely be considered as unofficial
Disney Princesses mogera from Hercules
where do we begin with mogera mogera aka
Meg is one of those independent and
quick-witted women that makes a Disney
movie instantly better her personality
matches the likes of Princess Jasmine
who's probably just as snarky alright
Megara my friends call me Meg at least
they would if I had any friends but
mogera is a heroine and refuses to be
anyone's romantic interest her negative
opinion of men represents her past
experiences it takes a lot of time for
her to even consider getting with
Hercules she's also known to be scared
of heights but she totally overcomes
that when she has to save Hercules his
life she also has plenty of flaws like
manipulating young Hercules with her
looks in order to get what she wants but
she's still by far one of those
characters with a person
that's far from your typical Disney
stereotype if there's a prize for rotten
judgement maybe that's why she never
really made it on the official Disney
princess list but she still has a place
there in our minds how could you not
fall in love with the sassy and
independent princess Meg my sweet
don't even go there if you've never seen
her before you definitely need to see
Hercules mcGarry's character will for
sure make you question why she wasn't
included on the official list Alon we
from the Black Cauldron here's another
name that probably doesn't ring any
bells unless you're a hardcore Disney
fan she belongs to the 1985 movie the
Black Cauldron meet princess alon me who
is a 12 year old girl with a very
typical Disney Princess look I thought I
heard a noise in here but her
personality is slightly different than
most as she's not afraid to talk back
and just like mogera she's immune to
boys charms obviously because she's 12
but you know age doesn't mean anything
in the Disney world along we might have
the typical Disney story of being a love
interest despite her age but she's so
much more than that
her best quality are her extensive rants
but she's also extremely affectionate
and can be quite emotional so she
definitely has a good mix of both that
would make her a perfect disney princess
many still don't understand why princess
Eilonwy wasn't given a Disney Hall of
Fame pass instead she became one of the
most forgotten princesses ever if it
weren't for this girl the entire movie
is absolutely adorable and a must-see
for anyone that needs a break from huge
Disney movies Maid Marion from Robin
Hood a lot of Disney fans tend to point
out that if other Forgotten princesses
are considered people should also
mention Maid Marion from Robin Hood
Robin Hood has had many adaptations
through the years and with it came many
portrayals of Maid Marian in the 1973
Disney movie Maid Marian is actually a
vixen while in the 2001 adaption Robin
Hood and Maid Marian are married and
they have a princess daughter but one
thing's for certain Marian is always
considered to be Robin Hood's love
interest who lucky surely you must know
how much I still love him she's pretty
much always presented as an admirer
Boleyn that's often noble and confident
her love for Robin that is completely
sincere and there are no strings
attached she also has an independent
side and what's likely most unique is
the Equality she has to Robin Hood
considering the times in which the
original Robin Hood was written this
makes Marian one of the most progressive
female characters in English literature
you go Marian besides why shouldn't she
belong on the Disney princess list
considering her daughter is also a
princess we're telling you kids today
missed out on a bunch of iconic
characters but we're not done yet
we just have to talk about these two
underrated characters Chiara from The
Lion King too Simba's pride when it
comes to lionesses Disney isn't really
giving them the praise they deserve
we'll talk about the ultimate lioness in
just a little bit but first we have to
discuss Knollys daughter
[Music]
Chiara might have appeared in the
underappreciated Lion King to Simba's
pride but that doesn't mean she doesn't
deserve to be on the unofficial Disney
princess list Chiara is one of those
rebellious and wild characters that
doesn't really like to be at home 24/7
she's pretty much just like her mother
she's actually the future queen of the
pride and although she resents it as a
kid she learns to accept it later as
future Queen what if I don't want to be
queen
it's not fun she's actually the future
queen of the pride and although she
resents it as a kid she learns to accept
it later on she's incredibly headstrong
which is always an admirer herbal traits
in any Disney Princess along with being
independent and self-sufficient Chiara
comes with a lot of attitude which is
especially aimed toward her older
brother let's just say there's a lot of
sibling rivalry going on she's just one
of those characters that doesn't take
advice seriously unless she can learn it
on her own father please reconsider you
will not go anywhere without an escort
from now on overall she has a pretty
well-rounded personality that definitely
deserves a place on the disney princess
list sure she might not be human but
let's be honest
Disney animal characters have always
been the best anyways Nala from The Lion
King
but if we talk about Kiara we have to
talk about the og because without Nala
there would be no Kiara I just heard
about this great place and Nala was the
ultimate totally forgotten character
that deserves a Disney Princess spot she
gets overshadowed in the movie by funny
characters like Timon and Pumbaa but we
can't forget just how brilliant she is
she's frequently considered to be a
Disney princess by the hardcore Disney
fans and we can definitely see why as a
kid Nala is extremely sassy and has a
lot of attitude so where are we going
it better not be anyplace dumb no really
cool but when she gets older she becomes
headstrong and ready to take on
responsibilities she's one of the most
sensible characters in the movie and
isn't afraid to verbally stand her
ground she's pretty much Simba's voice
of reason which is very much appreciated
you've been alive all this time
why didn't you come back to Pride Rock
and of course she was the one that
brought Simba back to Pride Rock in the
first place as a mother she is
absolutely amazing when it comes to
parenting Chiara and kion she later
becomes slightly more reserved when she
becomes a queen but that only makes her
cooler she's truly always able to bring
out the best in almost everyone which is
a perfect - Disney Princess trait BRB
time to rewatch The Lion King but before
you go make sure to tell us which
unofficial Disney Princess is your
personal favorite and why have we missed
any - let us know in the comments and
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more
feel-good content thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]